Southwest Airlines had this massive
meltdown operational meltdown flights
canceled baggage lost people stranded at
airports in some cases arrested simply
trying to get rebooked and Fox News had
a segment
during which they tried to blame
the Secretary of Transportation in the
Biden Administration Pete boot Edge
um it's absolutely ridiculous Richard
Fowler who I know a little bit was on
this panel along with Titus or Tyrus and
some other people a number of different
experts as you can imagine and he said
it's completely absurd to blame mayor
Pete let's take a listen to this
discussion meantime just sleeping at an
airport for anyone who's ever done it
not a good time so I just it's such a
great thing out there we have paid for
so many flights and bus trips for
illegals throughout this
um excellent point Tyrus Richard I'm
gonna ask you a sincere question and I'm
not saying this to people
are Democrats Democrats have a lot of
Hope in Pete Buda judge are they
embarrassed of just how he's performed
over the last couple years this is not
even about people to judge though let's
be very clearly no hold on 90 of the
flights that have been canceled in the
United States is from one Airline a
majority of the flights canceled around
the world is from one Airline so to sit
here and to blame this on the
transportation secretary when you have
one Airline and one irresponse it's not
even the employees of this Airlines
ninety percent of the airlock 90 of the
flights cancel the United States today
are from Southwest Airlines because you
have a bad management you have a they
have bad software you can't blame the
flight attendants you can't blame the
pilots you can't blame the ramp agents
you have to blame the people who sit in
the corporate Suites of Southwest
Airlines for canceling flights period
the end of story
the fact that Southwest can't manage
their place it's ridiculous
could they get buses just like they do
for legal this is so crazy people I mean
I mean sure but once again this is a
this is about capitalism and an airline
that cannot manage it don't fly
Southwest Airlines good point all right
up next liberal Okay so
is anybody else noticing how these small
government conservatives all of a sudden
become socialists when a private company
is failing and saying hey the people
we've been accusing of being socialists
for years the Biden Administration
they're not being socialist enough or
even communist and just managing what
this private company is doing so the
real reason that this meltdown took
place was the Southwest Airlines
internal management system got
completely overwhelmed they have a
complicated model for assigning flights
they have an Antiquated internal system
for managing and Staffing those trips
and Company officials and union leaders
and experts are all in agreement about
that
first and foremost the Secretary of
Transportation oversees the entire
Transportation sector so that includes
Aviation
Maritime Transportation highways Rail
and they have other things that they do
as well okay it's a big picture position
the Department of Transportation and
Pete Budaj as the Secretary of
Transportation the idea that it's Buddha
judge's fault that one Airline had a
massive meltdown because of their own
Antiquated system or to try to hold Pete
bootage responsible it's completely and
totally pathetic now let's go beyond
that because you could say well the
context in which this happened
is the responsibility of the Department
of Transportation or something
uh just about all of the things that
affect individual Airlines actually have
nothing to do with the Department of
Transportation you've got weather
weather is like a category that affects
flights maintenance issues deferred
maintenance stacking up and accumulating
and creating a problem Staffing
shortages
um employees getting sick for example as
we saw during the covet pandemic
technical problems it has nothing to do
with the Secretary of Transportation at
all now if you had
some new government decree that limited
the ability of Airlines to I don't know
do whatever it is they need to do and
you could specifically point to it as a
policy affecting all Airlines I would
listen there's no doubt about it but
this is this is absolutely and
completely absurd Pete butterjudge is
not an operational manager the Secretary
of Transportation has nothing to do with
the internal dynamics of Airlines and
doesn't influence day-to-day operations
in any way and this is just an attempt
to criticize Joe Biden's Administration
that that's really all it is but maybe
even more interesting is the hypocrisy
here
this Republican party these right
Wingers on Fox very low information
Republic I mean they go for the lowest
hanging fruit because that's what Their
audience expects the Republican party
has long espoused the belief
that government regulation is
unnecessary and it's bad for business
too much involvement from the government
is bad it's not that it's neutral it's
actually bad we should leave the private
sector to operate without interference
in this case they immediately say it
must be the federal government's fault
we should blame Pete butterjudge because
of the operational delays of one Airline
even despite all of the complex factors
that are that are involved there it's
absurd and they are pathetic and
understand that that segment we just
watched they are calling for government
Intervention when they say
Peach should have done more what they're
saying is the government should have
gotten more involved in the operations
of a single private Airline that's the
opposite of what they normally espouse
so the hypocrisy is galling and it
shouldn't really surprise us because
they're more interested in scoring
political points particularly With Their
audience who seems to have barely a clue
what's going on I mean this is not my
opinion I'm not editorializing you look
at studies that look at how informed are
people who primarily get their news from
Outlet a b c d the people who primarily
get news from Fox are of the least
informed people in one study people who
get their news from Fox are less
informed than people who don't even pay
attention to the news if you can believe
that it's unbelievable that's who this
message is tailored to
which ignores completely that they are
calling for the very thing which they
claim to oppose federal government
getting involved in the business of
Private Industry we'll have this clip on
our Instagram if you want to see it in
its full Glory you can find it by
searching Instagram for David packman
show you can also find me on Instagram
by searching for david.pakman
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping